would say to a person who had
sneezed He mentions here a
narration collected by both
Bukhari and Muslim that a man
came to the prophet and asked
him, what of Islam is most
virtuous? What's meant here is
those things that people do
naturally amongst each other.
What of these what of these you
know, dealings or what of these
interactions is most virtuous
in Islam. The prophet said, to
feed others and to convey a
salaam to those whom you know
and those whom you do not. So,
what's meant here by what of
Islam is most virtuous?
Obviously, salah is more
virtuous than this. Obviously,
fasting, the pillars of Islam.
There are actions that are more
virtuous but this is a very
specific type of virtue. It is
relative to what the questioner
had in mind. Clearly, we see
from the answer here, the
response of the prophet that
the is asking about something
very specific and that is
people's dealings with each
other, people's interactions,
what is most virtuous of these
interactions? He mentions,
feeding their stomachs, and as
well their hearts by conveying
a Salem.
Muslim, in Adama, Lama the
[Silence]
go to that group of angels over
there and convey a salaam to
them and listen closely to
their response. For indeed
their salutation to you shall
remain your salutation among
you and your offspring.
Meaning, this will be what your
offspring will salute one
another with. And so Adam
Alaihi Salam went to these
angels and he said assalamu
alaikum. And they responded
assalamu alaikum. So they added
onto his salaam. Likewise, in
both Bukhari and Muslim,
That's the prophet commanded
that people convey a salaam to
one another And that and he
promised that if they do convey
a salaam to one another openly
to those who know each other
and those who do not know each
other. What's meant here is are
those who are Muslim, a salaam
to initiate a salaam, to say a
salaam alaikum, to initi
another person with this
specific salutation. This is
for Muslims only. We only say
assalamu alaikum to Muslims. As
for if a person says that is
non Muslim the response is
different among different upon
amongst the scholars. The
opinion of the author Ibn al
Kaim, and also Sheikh Al Islam.
And many others. Is that a
person responds with. And we
will get into that inshallah.
What's what's what's intended
here is that if you know
someone is Muslim that you
should say assalamu alaikum to
them. Whether you know them or
you don't. This is the spirit
of the bond of Islam. That our
bond of Islam is that I love
all of the Muslims, those whom
I know, and those whom I do
not. Alright? This is the idea
of belief and brotherhood in
faith and belief. We see this
very often. A person will be
out you know, in a supermarket
or somewhere where especially
when it's, you know, usually
you don't bump into another
Muslim there and they walk by
each other nothing like,
you know, and they stare at
each other. They walk by and
stare at each other the whole
time. You know what I'm talking
about. We all we've all seen
it, right? And if you if they
know that you're Muslim,
they'll stare at you. If you're
there for 20 minutes, they'll
stare at you the whole time but
never will a salaam be
exchanged. This is, this is
highly disappointing. Likewise,
if you bump into another person
that is Muslim and you do say
assalamu alaikum, it's almost
they're shocked. It's
almost they're taking
aback and maybe you might get a
response, you know, you know,
this is unfortunate and
disappointing. And
unacceptable. We convey a
salaam to those whom we know
and those whom we do not. And
the
[Silence]
believe until we learn to love
one another.
Allah Ibn
the
[Silence]
traits. Now, obviously, faith
is to believe in Allah and the
angels and the books and the
messengers. What's meant here
by these three traits are true
faith is that these are the
fruits of true faith. If a
person really believes in Allah
and the last day and the books
and the angels and so forth. If
a person really has this belief
truly and it touches his heart
and it has its roots sprouting
in his heart. Then, this tree
will bear fruit. This faith
will manifest itself in a
person's actions. What are
these traits, these fruits? He
says, the first trait is that a
person is just and fair and in
judging himself and judging
himself. What's meant here by
fairness is that a person does
not judge himself based on his
ego. The ego is what we wish we
we we were. Or the ego is what
we to show other people.
rather what's meant here is
that a person looks at himself
objectively. Objectivity in
judging a person's own self.
This is where progress comes
from. If a person looks at
himself and says no I'm happy
with myself as it is. I
don't see that I'm doing
anything wrong. I'm fine. This
person is very far from the
path of redemption. and we see
this and we see this in our
popular culture now, right?
Popular culture is, you know, I
love myself and I love
everything about myself and
anyone who doesn't love
everything about me, then, you
know, they don't deserve to
have me and you know, they need
to love me for who I am. I
don't know exactly what is
meant by this but people do not
love one another essentially.
They love one another because
of each other's actions, right?
That's objectivity. That a
person is valuable based on
their actions. If their actions
are upstanding, they become
more valuable. And if their
actions are bad or harmful,
they become less valuable and
they may even become a
liability, right? and so, a
person needs to constantly
objectively view himself, to
view oneself with objectivity.
I look at myself and I see what
needs to be changed. I am
honest with myself and I'm not
afraid to be honest with
myself. This whole, you know,
embrace yourself and you know,
love yourself and these people
are unhinged and these people
usually have extremely,
extremely, extremely deeply
seat
you know, personality issues
when you look at their
lifestyle, you know, it's all
about I love myself and it's
kind of an an
overcompensation because they
really can't stand themselves
and often times, this is why
people who tout this can't
spend, you know, 10 minutes
alone with themselves without
having some phone in their face
or having some, you know,
person sitting there
distracting them from who they
are the point here is that a
person needs to view himself
objectively. A person looks at
himself with objectivity, he
will see what needs to be
changed and what needs to be
worked on. Doesn't mean a
person needs to, you know, beat
himself down to where, you
know, they have no confidence.
This is not what's intended but
what is intended is that a
person needs to see what needs
to be worked on. If you sit
down with yourself honestly and
write a list of, you know, 1 00
things that you wish you could
change or need to work on on
yourself, there's a problem.
There's a serious problem and
you know, there's this easy cop
that people do this cop out.
It's well, I'm not
perfect, you know? You hear
people say, I'm not perfect but
I am saying, no, I'm not
perfect. It's just glossing
over things and you know, it's
a cheap cop out. I'm not
perfect. You know, that's not
saying anything objective about
yourself. I'm not perfect
means, you know, it's this
fainting of fake humility. That
doesn't get us anywhere. What
needs to happen is that a
person honestly look at himself
and it takes courage. It takes
courage and it takes you know,
honesty and bravery to look at
yourself because who wants to
do that? Who wants to look in
the mirror and you know, come
to terms with the fact that you
know, I need a lot of fixing. I
need a lot of work. you
know, I may not be favorable to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. This
is a serious thing and these
are demons that we have to
exercise and so, the first
trait that the companion
mentions is viewing oneself
with objectivity. The second is
conve
to everyone and what's meant by
everyone here is every Muslim,
right? Salam is for Muslims and
the third is spending and
giving to others in spite of
your own hardship, in spite of
your own hardship. He goes on
to explain these traits. He
says, these three principle,
these three fundamental traits.
essentially
they
essentially contain or
entail all of good and
everything that comes from
good. How is that? He says, as
for a person being objective in
viewing himself, if a person
truly is objective when viewing
himself, meaning not biased to
himself. naturally, the
human being always views
himself as the victim. Always
views himself as giving others
and not receiving what he's
owed. This is the natural state
of being because people are
naturally selfish, right? And
so, usually people will magnify
any perceived slight from
another person and they will
mitigate anything that they do
against another person.
Likewise, they will magnify any
good that they do for another
person in their mind's eye and
they will mitigate good that
other do for them. That's the
natural state of the human
being. He says, when a person
becomes objective and unbiased
in viewing himself this will
bring about a person fulfilling
the rights of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala fully. A person, if
they have this trait, they will
no longer be of the camp of you
know, I'm just human. I'm not
perfect, and Allah will forgive
me and I've didn't done my best
and who who of us can honestly
say we've done our best. Who?
Who amongst us can stand up and
say, I am innocent, honestly.
None of us is innocent. We're
all guilty. None of us is
innocent and none of us has
done our best and that's how we
need to feel about it. And we
need to work and build on that.
He says, and this will also,
this trait will also carry a
person to and this trait will
also cause a person fulfill
other people's rights, not just
the rights of Allah but the
rights of other people as well
because they are unbiased. They
are looking at their exchanges
with people with objectivity.
And a person will start to
treat others as he wishes to be
treated. and another thing that
this trait will bring about in
a person is that the person
will view himself for what he
really is. So, he will not
claim merits or virtues that do
not belong to him. and
likewise, a person will not you
know, put out his soul's light
with disobedience to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. If a
person is truly objective with
himself and unbiased, a person
is not going to lay claim to
merit that doesn't belong to
him. Glory that doesn't belong
to him. Person sees himself for
what he really is. And that
will reflect himself, reflect
itself and his life and his
actions and speech, in as true
humility. True humility is not
what you say. True humility is
not how you stand. True
humility is how you view
yourself. Right? If you view
yourself with objectivity,
that's what breeds true
humility And again, you know,
as as people, as human beings,
we're very crafty in you know,
praising ourselves in a very
slick way, right? Or deflecting
blame in a very slick way.
You'll hear people when they
apologize, you know, if I've
done anything wrong, then, I
apologize for it but you know,
how is this an apology? If I've
done anything wrong, I mean,
god forbid, you know? And
likewise, people deflect as you
know,
our people will have this this
fake humility and this fake
selflessness, right? And this
urge to you know, put every
little thing they do on on the
internet for everybody to give
them a round of applause and a
standing ovation. You know,
you'll read the caption, you
know. eating homeless people
today, you know, and hey, how
are you? You know, what's your
name? they do that when
people aren't looking, right?
This is cheap and fake and it
cheapens the the the of a
person being a real human
being. If you honestly wanted
to be good to this person, you
wouldn't plaster their face and
their picture and their video
all over the internet. You
know, hey, guys. You know,
everybody, this is a poor
person. You see this? Homeless.
Right here. Right? That's not
how we treat people that are
less fortunate than ourselves.
but that that goes back to a
critical difference between the
Muslim and the non Muslim when
it comes to etiquettes and
character. there are parallels.
You know, there are Muslims
that are honest and there are
non Muslims that are honest,
right? But the honesty may
appear the same. But what that
honesty is rooted in is the key
difference between the Muslim
and the non Muslim. The Muslims
etiquettes, character, good
dealings is rooted in to his
belief and his relationship
with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
When I am honest, I feel like
when I am treating others well,
I am actually simultaneously
building a relationship with
Allah. This, you know, honesty,
integrity, whatever it is,
bravery, all of these things
are hardwired and deeply rooted
and grounded in our belief.
contrary to the non Muslim non
Muslim may have, you know,
truthfulness and and bravery
and all of these other things
but these things are rarely
rooted in their belief in Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Usually,
it is rooted in tradition or it
is rooted in business strategy
or it is rooted in whatever it
is they're trying to achieve.
So, often times, people will be
honest because it's in their
favor to be honest. A Muslim is
honest because in spite of
whatever transpires here, this
is building a relationship with
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. And
so the prophet when he was
asked what is what is
righteousness, piety, what is
it?
Yeah, yes,
no,
he said, piety is having good
etiquette, good character. This
is piety. So, our manners and
etiquettes are deeply rooted in
our beliefs. These are
etiquettes that we adorn
ourselves with because this is
what pleases Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. And this also changes
the effects that other people's
reactions to our etiquettes
will have. What do I mean by
that? Usually, people are
honest when it's in their
favor, right? Usually, people
are nice when it's in their
favor. It's good to smile, you
know, and and speak nicely to a
customer because that's how we
build a customer base. A
Muslim, we do these things
primarily because it is a type
of worship of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. Which where does the
difference really manifest
itself in the person's Action.
So, if if we receive a positive
reaction or not, we still
maintain these etiquettes. If
it's going to get me a more
positive reaction, should I
lie? No. We will tell the truth
even if it even if it merits a
poor reaction. Contrary to
those who have the same
etiquettes but these etiquettes
are not rooted in their belief
system and their relationship
with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
They're nice to people only as
long as they receive what
they're looking for of of you
know that a person is nice back
or that it but if if that
doesn't work then they will do
anything to get that same that
desired effect. and this is one
of the tribulations that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tests the
Muslims with He says subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
and then that we will put forth
the effort as dictated to us by
Allah and his messenger but the
fruits will will not be as
plentiful as we would hope. So,
this is a test. Is a person
going to change now his actions
to get the desired effects, or
as a person doing those actions
based on principle. I am not
doing this for the effects. I
am doing this out of worship of
Allah. And if those desired
effects come to fruition, then,
great and if they don't, I
still have my relationship with
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. This
is a type of test.
The